Chris reflections on last night the
morning after how does that feel it's
it's still sinking in still thinking
just the the magnitude of what we've
achieved it just feels strange that
we've been every morning for the for the
last three weeks been waking up
preparing ourselves for what lies ahead
that day what mountains we've got to
ride up and for the first time today
just being able to lie back again and
switch off and think you know what we've
done it now we can relax how much
satisfaction do you take from that
achieving the job achieving it in such
in such a grand manner you won by a long
way yeah um
can take a lot of satisfaction from it I
mean it really has been months and
months of preparation to get ready for
for an event like the Tour de France to
come away having having won it the way
we did really is very fantastic feeling
your road to Paris started a long way
away from the heart of cycling's
homeland in Europe in Kenya when when
did this sort of the spark first get lit
for you um as a kid I was always on my
bike
never never really in terms of
competition or or anything like that but
as I always just loved riding my bike
and I think that's that's never to
pretty where where this spark started
the love for the sport and I can tell
you that I wouldn't be here today if I
wouldn't be able to get on my bike and
train five six hours a day if if I
didn't love it you never felt that being
that I'm at mountain biking in near
Nairobi was any barrier to one day
getting here well back then it I didn't
think it would be possible but um
I think it just goes to show that if you
really want something badly enough
you're gonna find a way to make it
happen you mentioned your mother in your
speech on the podium last night and you
mention inspiration how much did you
call on that during the race itself the
word the were moments when I thought
that's one of the reasons why why I'm
here that's one of the reasons why I'm
going through this when when the legs
are screaming at you to slow down and
stop and I could reflect and think well
actually I'm doing this for a bigger
reason I'm doing it from for more people
and then just for myself personally and
it's definitely helped to keep the
motivation up you're it's the first tool
window Brailsford already says it's you
can win more do you feel like you can do
this again you can win this race again
I'd love to be back I'd love to be back
and to to make this something that I
target for as long as I can during my
career I mean I I feel extremely
privileged to to being given opportunity
once to to come here and to try and win
it and yeah if I can have this
opportunity again in the future odds I'd
definitely go for it you've got the
yellow jersey there you said last night
in the podium that it would stand the
test of time what did you mean if you
look at the the history that history of
our sport and especially the the
revelations from from last year from
from a decade ago now I think it's only
fitting to to let people know that the
sport has changed that it's no longer a
sport where people are cheating to to
get ahead and this is one one yellow
jersey that that will stand the test of
time it's not going to get stripped and
yeah I mean we've we've come under a lot
of scrutiny during the race and I I
completely accept that people have been
let down in the past personally I've
been let down I have I was a big big fan
of of those races back then and it
really does make a mockery of of things
when when when titles get stripped so I
just wanted to put it out there and let
people know that this is one yellow
jersey that that is not going to get
stripped you you face those questions
you mentioned and there were did you
feel an extra burden as well as
everything else you had to contend with
this race you're carrying that the
faster you go the louder the questions
go it definitely added another another
aspect to our race something that maybe
we hadn't anticipated quite quite as
much as the impact it had on us it was
it was quite hard to deal with I mean
people basically saying that asking
questions about if we're complete fraud
in what we're doing and that makes it
pretty hard when when you know you've
spent months and months and months
training and really really working hard
to get here by virtue of what you've
achieved you're effectively the the
leader of that peloton now do you sense
that the riders in that peloton have
changed in their cycling has moved on
it's not just about what you and teams
can attack
definitely definitely there's definitely
a mood in the peloton that it just it's
not going to be accepted now and you can
even see guys from the past you have
served suspensions and and bans there
they're definitely not popular at the
moment and okay I can only see the sport
carrying on in this manner and going
going forward in that regard and tell me
how does after over two thousand miles
and three weeks in the settle how do you
relax you have a rest or you probably
may be racing good question oh I will
relax but I'm gonna carry on in Belgium
and Holland and do a few smaller lower
key circuit races criteriums for the
next ten days or so
so not quite the relax the relaxing that
most people would have in mind but still
a bit of fun
you'll start that way this evening this
evening